He's played a young Mandalorian and a
Tusken Raider? This celebrity's nephew
is carving out a spot for himself
in Star Wars and so much more.
As if there weren't enough reasons to check out
"The Book of Boba Fett," "Star Wars" fans needed
to watch it to understand what's going on in
"The Mandalorian" Season 3. Over the course
of a couple of episodes, we see Din Djarin
getting exiled from the Mandalorian way. He's
also reunited with his little buddy Grogu, who's
been learning the ways of the Jedi. Basically,
it sets up everything you need to know going
into a new season of "The Mandalorian." Needless
to say, the first episode of Season 3
really kicks things off with a bang.
The episode opens with a traditional Mandalorian
baptism ceremony. The Armorer crafts a helmet
for a young Mandalorian child, who is eagerly
awaiting this rite of passage. Unfortunately,
the ceremony is interrupted by a giant monster,
as often happens in a galaxy far, far away. But
the monster may not have been the only thing to
catch your attention. The child getting baptized
may have looked familiar to you, especially
if you tune into a lot of Disney+ originals.
The young actor's name is Wesley Kimmel,
and that last name is no coincidence. He is,
indeed, the nephew of late-night
talk show host Jimmy Kimmel,
but he's quickly becoming
an actor in his own right.
Wesley's resume is building up nicely.
While he initially appeared periodically
on episodes of "Jimmy Kimmel Live!," he's
since popped up in various films and TV shows,
including "The Rookie" and "Good Girls."
However, he appears to be carving out a
nice niche for himself on Disney+. He stars
as the Commercial Boy in a few episodes of
"WandaVision," and he played a Tusken Kid
on the first three episodes of "The Book of
Boba Fett." He must've made a good impression
on somebody, as now he's rejoined "Star Wars"
for "Chapter 17" of "The Mandalorian."
Most recently, Wesley Kimmel could be
found playing Jack in the Netflix original
film "Your Place or Mine," starring Reese
Witherspoon and Ashton Kutcher. It's also
been confirmed that he'll appear in the
upcoming Amazon Prime Video movie "Red One,"
so he's certainly keeping busy these days.
"It was dope. My mom would've
never let me watch that."
Wesley's inclusion in two "Star Wars" properties
is made possible by the fact that viewers didn't
get a chance to see his face in "The Book
of Boba Fett." He's a child Tusken Raider,
and as such, he wears a mask obstructing his face
for any scenes he's featured in. This makes it
easy for the young actor to come back to play a
Mandalorian child in "The Mandalorian" Season 3.
In many ways, "The Book of Boba Fett"
turned into "The Mandalorian" Season 2.5,
thanks to the inclusion of fan favorites Mando
and Grogu. But one thing it did exceptionally
well was flesh out the Tusken Raiders as
actual characters as opposed to plot fodder,
and they played an integral
role in Boba Fett's journey.
Rory Ross, who plays one of the Tusken Raiders
on the show, opened up about what it was like
to be part of such a massive "Star Wars"
property. In an interview with Looper,
Ross actually gave a shout out to the
young Kimmel for playing the Tusken kid.
Pointing out how important the character
was for Boba Fett's arc, Ross told Looper,
"The little Tusken kid, played by Wesley Kimmel,
represents Boba as a child and him, his innocence
and everything else when his father passes
away and we see that on Geonosis in Episode 2."
It remains to be seen if the
Mandalorian child will factor
into the larger machinations of
the show during Season 3. However,
it's already clear that Wesley Kimmel is
proving to be a valuable asset to Disney.